this next story would not be believable
if we hadn't been seeing exactly this
type of projection for the last who
knows how many years from the american
republican party
herschel walker the trump-endorsed
republican senate candidate from georgia
has been a big critic of absentee
fathers in fact he's run a campaign
very much based around cultural issues
critical race theory which he misstated
as ctr which is usually an abbreviation
for click-through rate which is an
online advertising term anyway he meant
crt he's been talking about crt he's
been talking about absentee fathers and
all of these different things
we had two layers of insanity first it
was revealed that herschel walker
actually has
another son he has one son that kind of
is in the public eye named christian
walker
it was revealed that herschel walker has
another son
that he doesn't see he
is an absentee father to another son
after that story came out it was
revealed that herschel walker actually
has
even more kids to whom he is an absentee
father i guess we would say he is not
really a father is every allegation a
confession from these people so let's go
through it piece by piece and then we'll
talk about the hypocrisy so first we
have an article from the new york times
this is from two days ago and the
article says kershaw walker critic of
absentee fathers has a second son that
he doesn't see the article is from maya
king
herschel walker the republican nominee
for senate from georgia who has often
spoken out against absentee fathers
particularly in black households on
tuesday publicly acknowledged having
fathered a second son with whom he is
not in contact
the admission came in response to a
report by the daily beast which said it
confirmed ten-year-old boy's parentage
but withheld his name and that of the
mother it says the child's mother has
sued walker a year after giving birth to
obtain a declaration of paternity and
child support and the suit lasted until
august 2014 when walker was ordered to
pay child support the boy by then more
than two years old took walker's last
name
okay so that's already crazy like that
that's already wow so you're going out
there saying not just in general we have
a problem with absentee fathers but in
the black community we have a problem
with absentee fathers and he is he is
part of that problem okay
but then it gets even crazier because
then this morning
another piece comes out in the daily
beast herschel walker critic of absentee
dads admits to yet another secret sun
and it's this isn't the first secret sun
that was reported this is another one
this arctic used by article is by roger
sullenberger and it says a day after the
daily beast broke the news that herschel
walker had a secret 10 year old son
the football star turned politician
confirmed late wednesday he has yet
another son with a different woman
as well as a daughter that he had in
college
walker said in september of 2020 i want
to apologize to the african-american
community because the fatherless home is
a major major problem he added in an
interview with diamond and silk men need
to go into neighborhoods and become
fathers of those fatherless children
the second of walker's previously
undisclosed sons was born to a woman
living in texas and is now 13. walker's
other son is 10
christian walker who's the publicly
known one is 22.
the daily beast is con withholding the
names of the younger sons and their
mothers
um there's a bunch of different layers
to this story okay
first it's the heavy projection that we
are constantly seeing from the
republican party
um trump's about family values
supposedly evangelicals vote for me i
love the bible and i love two
corinthians and all this different stuff
um except trump's been divorced multiple
times and he's cheated endlessly and he
has uh children with with different
women and all these things that the
evangelicals claim to care about and
trump says vote for me anyway and then
they do because they really don't like
hillary clinton okay so like that's one
layer the double standard the hypocrisy
that that's certainly um part of this
but there's also kind of another element
to this
which is
the republican party at this point
only cares about virtue signaling around
these issues rather than actual policy
and they apply different standards to
their own than to others and this is
unfortunately it's not something that we
can fix
because you can't get other people to
actually care about being consistent if
you have to remember that the way the
republican party works right now is they
say it's basically this thought process
democrats are evil socialist communists
uh whatever baby killing right all the
different stuff sodomites some of them
like to say whatever it is that they say
they start with that so we absolutely
can't have any democrats in office we've
got to vote for republicans the reason
we claim that we do that is because the
republicans are pro-life and the
republicans are pro-family and they're
godly and they have faith in all of
these different things oh okay well look
at trump trump's a guy who was
pro-choice his entire life until he all
of a sudden needed to come up with some
explanation for being pro
anti-choice pro-life as they call it to
run for president
and he's been divorced and he's cheated
and he's not religious he never went to
church but i don't know now he says he
likes the bible okay even though it's
obvious that trump doesn't meet any of
their requirements remember they hate
hillary
they're not going to vote for the for
the democrats so they go we'll accept it
we'll accept trump's bogus story about
how he came to be against abortion and
will accept trump's bogus story about
how now he's religious and two
corinthians and all of that and then
it's proven to be false time and time
again
and they just go oh yeah well no but we
it doesn't matter i mean hillary was
even worse hillary's just absolutely
terrible it's never actually about any
of the things they claim it's about it
never is it's just a justification to
create a context to keep voting for the
people that say the right things even if
they're completely unbelievable now it
this will be a test for herschel walker
in georgia georgia has become very sort
of weaponized trumpist as we saw
but at the same time
in the in some of the primaries in
georgia the trump endorsed candidate
didn't win and even though trump did
endorse herschel walker
this may be too much for these georgia
voters now the funny thing about it is
i would be willing to accept
if herschel walker from the beginning
did a sort of do as i say not as i do
thing
i don't think that that's completely
illegitimate i don't i like i would be
willing to accept someone being upfront
and saying listen i think that we have a
problem
in general or in the black community
however he wants to phrase it with
absentee fathers and unfortunately i'm a
part of that problem i did xyz
and i'm not in touch with these kids and
it's been bad for me and it's been bad
for the kids and it's been bad for the
mothers and uh i am going through a
journey of personal rediscovery and i am
trying to make amends and fixing
you you guys know what i'm saying if he
just owned it i think you could still
credibly say and because i know this
issue so personally
it's a really important one that i want
to work on that's not what he did okay
he didn't do that and so now there's
going to be a question as to whether
this is the straw that breaks the
camel's back with these georgia voters i
don't know if it's going to be but we're
going to follow it and we will see